this is a production of Cornell
University so as I think most of you
know or now all of you definitely know
I'm tier I'm in Rebecca's lab and today
I'm going to be talking about basically
two very different views like a very
micro and a very macro view of the same
path or system the main sinister
psychopathy system disease pictured here
so we've kind of introduced or really
been focusing or thinking about this
intellectual model like this so to speak
it's like paradigm of different scales
of resistance in Rebecca's lab in the
past few years so kind of moving from
the molecular scale resistance like
chemical warfare
you know the interactions of different
genes all the way up to you know
landscape resistance what genes are
deployed where what's being grown where
what's the epidemiology of the pathogen
and to look at each of these you know
you obviously need to construct a
different experiment to explore each of
these things at its own scale so you
know that's what we've done in a
molecular you know on the molecular side
of things that the molecular scope of
things you know use an rna-seq
experiment to see what genes what
pathways what molecular mechanisms are
important at a given time on the tissue
side of things you know the path the the
pathogen is moving through a
three-dimensional leaf you know it's
it's not homogeneous so we've been doing
histopathology experiments to study that
on the plot level you know gene mapping
look at looking at resistance in the
field you know on a rotary basis looking
at natural diversity etc and on the
landscape level now you know just in the
past two years moving to aerial
photography drones and so you know like
Rebecca said I've been involved in a lot
of different things you know growth
chamber experiments are in a seek
experiment system pathology things often
kind of like jumping in on different
projects maze transposon mutagenesis was
one of my main projects gene mapping I
think but phenotyping writing a couple
reviews at the Bekaa but I'm gonna
basically focus on two main things you
know dividing it up into this micro and
macro view micro being an RNA seek
experiment using our gene isolines that
were wrapping up the paper now for
and on the macroscale what's been
funding me for the past two years which
is genomics or high-throughput
genotyping project about aerial imaging
of northern leaf blight so some
background if you've heard me talk
basically ever in the past five years or
if you've been in a cornfield you're
familiar with northern leaf blight it's
a fungal disease the foliar disease
it occurs in cool wet areas like Central
New York State it causes these nasty
necrotic lesions that you can see here
and as you might imagine that's gonna
lead to lower yield and also lower
silage quality so fewer available
nutrients certainly in terms of
quantifying its effect about and will be
specifically there's been I don't know
new interest or resurgence of interest
in the past few years because it's been
becoming a more serious problem
so some estimates of you know estimated
yield loss from 2016 for the years prior
you know the best estimate of this team
of plant pathologists was that in 2015
an Obie was accounting for about 25% of
all Mays disease yield loss incurring
penalty or economic loss of about two
billion dollars but it always looks more
dramatic and striking when you see it at
actions this is a photo taken by a
longtime lab manager to a coal bin not
far from here and what you can see is
that you know when you have the right
weather conditions which we often do in
central New York when you had the
pathogen population there when you have
a non resistant or susceptible variety
you know you can get these devastating
outbreaks the causal agent is this
fungus set us free at turcica and the
really critical things I think first and
foremost about its biology are one it's
heavy by a trophic that is it starts as
a bio troph feeding off living maize
cells
feeding off living tissue and
essentially trying to avoid detection or
avoiding detection then it switches into
a necro trophic phase in which it's
killing off the host tissue and living
off that dead tissue and that's the
necrotic lesions that you saw you know
before it's also haploid like most fungi
and it mostly so it can undergo sexual
reproduction meiosis but mostly it's
asexual reproduction so these are the
asexual spores that's the vast source of
you know inoculum in the disease
pressure and that's how you get
he's like lineages that cover a large
area so what does pathogenesis look like
this is a freeze-frame from a video that
I'll play in just a second but this is
from one of the histopathology
experiments I was running in the growth
chamber so the orange is the maize leaf
the green is the fungal tissue and what
you can see is there's a Canadian so
there's the asexuals forest thousands or
tens of thousands of them laying down
the leaf germinate I try to penetrate
the leaf it grows through the meze of
fill and then after I don't between 1
and 3 weeks depending on where you are
and the resistance etc etc it's gonna
reach the xylem and then it colonizes
xylem very rapidly
you know it's moving along the xylem it
can branch out of it that's why you get
those you know long skinny lesions it's
moving along the vascular tissue so
here's a video both that shows it in a
little bit clearer detail and also it's
just very neat this is a single spore or
you know looking at an extremely fine
detail and once you see this so this is
you know probably on this tissue you
would not be able to see any sort of
lesion you know just with your eye but
eventually what's gonna happen is that
it'll keep going throughout this
vascular bundle or like keep going
throughout that xylem expand branch out
into other vascular bundle and other
parts of vascular tissue and eventually
clog it essentially and start killing
off the host tissue so what do we know
about and I'll be a resistance well a
lot but quickly summarizing it so you
know this is kind of dichotomy of
qualitative and quantitative resistance
I'm gonna start with qualitative so like
RG mediated resistance there are four
canonical so to speak long known are
genes the HT genes in this pappa system
HT is short for helmet this for iam
turcica an outdated name for the fungus
and kind of like with the standard gene
for gene model you know as expected
you've got this gene for gene
interaction with AV rh t jeans a
virulence h t genes in the fungus series
what it looks like these are from pics
of greenhouse experiments by former grad
student Rebecca's challenge young you
know here's a it without an R gene here
is it with one of two different our
genes or the interesting things
about just even with only these four
genes is that you know we have different
effects if not all of these even on the
like level that's visible to your eye
are affecting the pathogen in a
different in the same way so HD to that
you can see here doesn't delay the
formation of lesions they still show up
around ten days afterwards but it does
so their growth and you get lots of this
chlorotic yellowing babies think it's
clear on the TV and HTN you know
pictured here on the right it does not
so the the rate of growth of the lesions
but it does greatly delay their
formation so it's good you know acting
at different points resistance is not
all the same and one of the interesting
things is that so far it so not many of
these genes are actually confirmed known
or cloned but of the two that are there
basically they're not the standard sort
of our gene and AVR gene so the our gene
that is cloned is HTM which is a wall
associated kinase and you know this is
not most our genes and the kind of
canonical model or the typical our gene
you know is a cytosolic gene is a
cytosol chain with a nucleotide binding
and loosing rich repeat domain and HTN
is not this it's kind of part of the
smaller category like 1/4 to 1/3 of
known are genes that are not really
fitting in that mold AVR ht1
in the fungus which go in terrence group
has been working on you know most fungal
effector genes are small secreted
proteins so they're about 20 amino acids
the fungus secretes them and they
interfere with the host defenses AVR ht1
is not that rather it's a secondary
metabolite gene that has both polyketide
synthase and non-ribosomal peptide
synthase domains so it's making its you
know it is a protein which is assembling
other very very small proteins same
dorky tides you know obviously or our
genes is not the entirety of what we
know about resistance so in terms of
quantitative resistance you know i'm
dividing these up but you know it is a
spectrum and i think everybody kind of
operates with this idea that you know
both there are these two kinds but there
is a spectrum obviously between
quantitative and qualitative resistance
but in terms of quantitative you know
there's lots of qtls there's lots of
diversity for resistance so this is an
image i really like from jesse poland's
paper on NLB resistance in the maze nan
population and you can just see you know
this is what the range of natural
diversity in terms
NOP resistance looks like Randy why sir
one of Rebecca's old students or former
students you know did a meta-analysis
just from a few different mapping
studies and you know the NLB qto from I
think five mapping studies called it
covered 40% of the genetic map Jesse
found 29 qto and you can see from down
here you know most of the QTL are
present across or at least the low sigh
heavily across most of the germ plasm
and again I won't cover this but I think
it's an interesting parallel kind of to
what we see with the our genes
specifically h t2 and HT n is that
challenge
chung another former grad student of
Rebekah's did this really interesting
work about QTL isolines so qto also can
have different effects so she's working
with these two QTL isolated from the
resistant line text me oh three now both
on chromosome one that fairly far apart
and one of them basically may believe
harder to penetrate so fewer conditio
could penetrate but it didn't slow their
growth one of them slowed the growth
post penetration but didn't
significantly reduce their ability to
penetrate beliefs so again we already
are going into this with this idea of
like uh you know they're operating at
different points spatially temporally
chemically etc so moving on to what I've
been working on
again the micro scale is mostly going to
be about this rna-seq experiment and the
experimental design of this basically
has two parts because we're interested
in looking at multiple things so the
first part is the host and pathogen
combinations so we are inoculating one
of two maze hosts which does or does not
have amazed our gene ht2 with one of two
pathogen isolates which do have their
own genetic differences but the critical
one is that they either have the wild
type capital letters a virulence gene or
the non wild-type you know little
letters a virulence gene and so what
that means in terms of our gene and AVR
genes so this is kind of the classic
gene for gene model of our genes is that
if you have the our gene and the
pathogen has a cognate Wow type AVR gene
you know we say Wow recognizable AVR
a virulence gene you induced this
resistance reaction like the one we sell
few sides before you were you induced
that chlorosis and that restrictive
nation growth if you know the host is
missing the our gene obviously it's
gonna be susceptible whereas
susceptibility background line is or if
the pathogen has the non recognizable
form of this AVR locus it's going to be
a susceptible interaction the second
component of it is that we also want to
know about this bio trophy necro trophy
transition because how many by atrocious
are there are really interesting model
because you can compare them both the
bio trophy fungi and to necro trophic
fungi and there's hemi bio trophy that
works differently among you know
different clades of organisms and
pathogens so in here what we're doing
you know the bio trophy necro trophy
transition and most germplasm in a
growth chamber happens typically before
10 days usually around eight or nine
days after you ovulate so we sampled at
four different time points days post
inoculation three five seven and ten and
so we've got three time points within
the by trophic phase and then ten ten
points in the negative phase and then
there's appropriate negative control so
you know knock inoculated maze plants on
the host side and the pathogen side we
have just pathogen isolettes growing in
a you know petri dish and culture and we
have a lot of questions that we have
asked and answered and you know but i
think are really fascinating but I'm
really gonna focus on a small set of
them under kind of two umbrellas the
first being exploratory questions
obviously like an RNA seek data set or
Eddie you know large-scale data set has
a lot of exploratory questions to ask
the ones that you know I think are
really fascinating for this are what
does the bio trophy necro trophy
transition look like in both the host in
the pathogen what is the difference
between a resistant and susceptible
interaction and then you know we have
ht2 mapped we have AVR h2 to mat you
know somewhere in our transcript reads
are the genes we're looking for can we
use like wise things like wise criteria
to narrow down our very long candidate
list and so keeping this experiment
straight I think this is the most
helpful plot what we have is on the
x-axis the days post inoculation each
line is a host path
combination and y-axis is basically what
percentage of the reads allowing to have
fungus you know essentially fungal
biomass by percentage of the samples
were taking from those leaves and the
first thing to point out is that you
know between seven and ten days what
does the bio trophy Nicko trophy
transition look like among other things
it's a rapid increase in fungal biomass
this is really when it takes off once it
hits that and I won't show the pca is
but essentially from three five and
seven days doing this by atrophic phase
the pathogens gene expression is the
same at all those time points it's just
reaching for the xylem not much is
changing that we can detect quite
similar second one is that you know this
is what an RG mediated resistance looks
like hd2 is inhibiting the growth of new
york one because new york one has the
recognizable form of the AVR ht2 locust
you know what we think of as the
wild-type the third point is that ht2
does not have an effect on the
twenty-eighth a isolate which is you
know this is a nice look which is
carrying the non recognizable form or
you know it's either mutated and missing
or something or there's somehow
different you know it does not have an
effect on the growth and the fourth one
I don't touch on this I won't touch on
this in the discussion but it's a really
fascinating point is that 28a is
essentially a better pathogen it's more
vigorous and we've always noticed this
you know anecdotally anyone who's worked
with these two isolates has seemed like
okay this one's great that one doesn't
grow super well it doesn't in check
super well and so we are also able and
won't let go into this at all but we are
also able to say okay what's the
difference between when you have no are
gene that is they're both susceptible
interactions what do a weak and a strong
pathogen look like and what is a host
responding to a weak and a strong
pathogen look like and how are they
different because these isolates that'll
in a lot of genes and will like a lot of
portions of the genome are 100%
identical so one thing people like to
ask when they do a paired RNA seek
experiment you know the common thing is
to say okay when I infect its host with
an OB or when I spray an OB on to this
host you know looking at both genomes
both transcriptomes
what do the genes do do they go up or
down and then you know characterize that
and some sort of
so we've worked pretty hard to basically
you know change this from a list of
200,000 p-values into something you know
tangible or understandable that we can
put in sort of literature form you know
prose as it were and so what we found
basically was the most useful the most
informative was using p fam domains so
what sort of proteins are they predicted
to be in the hosting pathogen and then
you know we can separate them out and
kind of parse and break this down into
you know an understanding of it
biologically by separating out by time
by hosting by pathogen and I'm just
gonna focus here on maze domains
breaking down kind of the bio trophy and
neckerchief you don't Mane's but I think
tell a really interesting story about
what Hemi bio trophy looks like so what
this figure is is a subsection of a
figure from the paper on each row are
the different pfam terms and I'll go
through them and get what the
significance is on the columns are the
time points 3 5 7 and 10 and then each
of those four squares is basically our
four combinations of hosts and pathogen
took a lot of finagling ticket a lot of
stuff on to this figure but um so some
things that we've found we would have
been more surprised if they hadn't shown
up so during these are key fam domains
which are enriched among the maze genes
upregulated during by a trophy no three
five seven days predominantly so the
first is you know new scene repeats and
nucleotide binding domains and in this
paper system as well wall associated
kinase is you know those are the
classical form of genes which detect
fungal effectors and/or pathogen
associated molecular patterns again
that's something that's totally not
surprising to see and we see it again
what we know of especially about NBL or
our gene regulation is that you know
once the plant detects that there is a
microbe you know attempting to infect
the leaf it up regulates like all of
these genes other things basically are
attested to in the literature for other
diseases but they're kind of this is the
first time that they're popping up on
our radar selectins or you know an anti
microbial protein that's been studying a
lot of other pasture systems but we've
never looked at them but kind of raises
a new hypothesis other things are not
very well tested in the disease
literature
but we can kind of make sense of them so
plaque 8 is a domain originally
characterized in humans which is why
it's plus sent a specific 8 but we can
kind of make sense of it because when
you look at what this gene does in
plants you know there's a common
implication of it's sensing mechanical
damage and it's involved in calcium
signaling things that make a lot of
sense in terms of disease response and
then we get these things that are very
very strange and I actually you know I
find these extremely exciting because so
many chromosome maintenance genes the
class of DNA helicase is they've been
implicated in diseases but only in
diseases where unconstrained DNA
replication is a logical part of the
life cycle and other diseases strategies
so like a soybean cyst nematode they're
trying to induce like wrap it on
unconstrained cell proliferation this is
the first time MCM genes are showing up
and even there it's it's a little
limited in terms of the literature is
the first time it's showing up in a
disease like this where you don't have
inducement by the pathogen of
unconstraint cell code one you know
general wage kind of wave it away is
like maybe this is a generalist stress
response because MCM genes have also
been implicated in response to you know
salt stress and drought stress I have
this kind of crazy hypothesis that it
could be involved in neutrophil
extracellular traps that is unspooled
chromatin but the plant releases to you
know trap up pathogen there's a reason
why this is kind of a crazy out there
hypothesis but I think it's really
exciting to see something that is just
not present in the literature that we're
the first to see this and notice this
very strong signal for these genes and
then you know moving to necro trophy I'm
gonna kind of skip over the ones that
are induced throughout the whole
lifecycle or the whole you know range of
times straight to so these are pfm
domains which are upregulated or many of
them are up regulated by the host
specifically during necro fee and so
again you know what we get is the
ability to put this into words that we
can understand and kind of synthesize
with our understanding of biology
instead of just a long list of p-values
and upregulation like log changes so
adapt ins and adp ribosylation factors
are FGM n--'s
you know if you're familiar with them
there
bounine vesicle secretion a secretion of
xenobiotic compounds you know good if I
own as transferases G STS are a class of
genes we've been interested for like you
know now like a decade you know because
they have known roles in detoxification
of pathogen compounds and in response to
nekros and then again you know sometimes
you just get an am no apical meristem is
just a class of transcription factor
domain it could be doing a million
different things it's kind of hard to
parse out but it is good to know that
that is there and recognize it and keep
it in the literature in that like a
usable form so these lines were made are
these lines that we were using we're
isolines that either do or don't carry
the h2 to our gene what we know about
ht2 so it has been mapped to a pretty
small region of chromosome eight by two
of Rebecca's former students you know
it's met pretty nicely
it is incredibly near the HTN our gene
and again that was a wall associated
kinase not the kind of cytosol like NBS
and our our gene that is common for our
genes and there are a whole lot of
kinase genes in that region that are
like there's dozens and dozens of pretty
plausible candidates when you just look
at okay what genes are here what did we
think they do do they look like known
resistance genes and the thing that we
are you know we're using the mantra like
work hard to not work hard you know
somewhere in these reads in the
transcript weeds we have the Trent the
RNA sequence the coding sequence of ht2
can we use intelligible criteria you
know to basically parse out our very
very long list of candidates so no we
just came up with a list you know one by
one of these logical criteria it should
be in or near the mapping region you
know it's precisely mapped but you know
it could be at least a few hundred KB
away does it make sense in terms of what
sort of gene it is is it polymorphic
between the two lines because we can you
know do de novo assembly of the
transcripts that align we can do two
novo assembly of all the transcripts and
say okay where are the polymorphisms are
there any how does it compare also to
what's already been sequenced in days it
has genome sequence is it expressed in
the leaf because if it's not expressed
base line you know just in a non
inoculum leaf and it's not induced it's
probably not doing anything
from the plant and as well does it have
higher expression in HT - because there
are our genes where there is you know
there are cases where there is no
polymorphism between two alleles of an R
gene it's about the regulatory control
of it instead so kind of looked at all
these logical criteria and it allowed us
to narrow down our list from 100 200
genes pretty narrowly down and I think
we have two strong candidates for HT -
and I think especially one of the nice
things is when you go in and look at the
sequence of these reads you know you can
find things that before we're really at
the top of our list we say oh this makes
perfect sense for HT - this is a perfect
candidate gene and then you look and you
say there's no polymorphism expressed
exactly the same you can't find any
difference between these two genes
between the isolines
you know we can use what we have in hand
to say that needs to go down the list
this other one needs to move up so the
first one is again these are both the
protein kinase is things involved in
signal detection
it has homology to a wall associated
kindness in rice its close-ish to the
mapping Center not as close as we would
like again we're at first we were
looking at okay let's just look at the
five genes right near the mapping thing
but we know that recombination can be
kind of iffy in this region you know
it's expressed in the leaf it is induced
by n will be infection and it's
polymorphic and the other nice thing is
that the HT - - allele pretty closely
matches b73 which we know does not have
HT - so it fits in with what we know
about that we did look at other genomes
because a lot you know more and more are
being sequenced every year but we're not
as confident about whether or not those
genomes have HD 2 etc second one you
know again we've got an leucine-rich
repeat domain which is a classical
domain involved in you know associated
with disease resistance genes
- protein kinase it's got much higher
expression in our HT - plus isoline and
again there's polymorphisms and HT - -
allele which is from a lioness xi which
is really similar be simply closely
resembles b-70 freeze version of this
team and so you know I
we would need to we have some money for
transgenic or transformation with net
Willman in the new plant transformation
facility you know all these need to be
confirmed but I think the nice thing
about looking at what you have in hand
is that you can turn a list of dozens of
fairly plausible candidates they're all
baby on equal footing into two much
stronger kids so moving from these kind
of exploratory questions into the more
hypothesis driven one you know we also
do have things that we hypotheses that
we bring to the experiment and say we
want to know if this is true in our
system or not and the two we'll focus on
are on the host side gene expression
versus resistance in the field and on
the pathogen side gene sparse region so
the hypothesis that were bringing to the
table in terms of an OB phenotype in the
field is that NLB resistance is related
to the baseline expression the non
induced expression of not an ocular
plants of genes that are upregulated in
response to NLB there are a lot of
reasons why this is you know a
moderately plausible hypothesis or this
might be the case you know lines can
have a resistant line might have high
like what we call a hair-trigger might
have high sensitivity towards fungal
domains or you know microbial signals it
might have really high based on
expression you know basically pre
constitutive defenses there also a lot
of reasons why this would totally not be
the case because you know induced
Express induced defenses and baseline
you know constitutive defenses are
different for a reason you don't always
want to be panicking and have all of
your defensive mechanisms firing on all
cylinders but also is because you know
one of the reasons why brought us the
table is we had the data to ask this
interesting question Carl Kremmling
published a paper this year which I
think a lot of people saw off you saw
his exit seminar it's really fascinating
and woody you know uploaded all the data
from this and it is gene expression in a
lot of different tissues for the maze
282 diversity panels so a lot of diverse
lines Judi cochlear has taken NOP
resistance metrics on the same panel so
you can compare the expression of genes
in multiple tissues to what at our
assistant is the adult plant the way
we're doing that is just with Ridge
regression we measure the accuracy
predictions by 10-fold cross-validation
say this metric of okay you know our is
related as kind of a vague term what
we're looking for is how well can we
predict NLB resistance from expression
of these genes using those as the
predictors and so what we have here is
the y-axis is the correlation between
the predicted and the observed values
the x-axis is how many genes were using
to predict and whether those genes the
two panels are whether those genes are
just randomly sampled from the genome
after we filtered for you know they
should be expressed there should be
diversity it should be a useful
predictor we don't want to throw garbage
in there or are they from our list of
kind of NLB induced genes and then as
you can see you know in both of them as
you add more predictors you get a better
prediction you know as you expect and so
what we see is when you're using the
small amount of genes that should be
0.16 change that but it's about twice as
good when you're using NLB induced genes
and so what I mean by twice as good is
that if you limit your predictors to
genes which are induced by an O being
you say from these I will predict and
I'll be resistance in adult plants you
do about twice as good a job as just
using expression of some randomly
sampled genes of the same number as you
increase the number of genes that get
you know more similar because if you
just increase the number to 35,000 genes
newbies the exact same gene sets using
all the genes but when you're using 3000
you know there's still about a there's
still about a point one bump in
prediction accuracy when you're limiting
this to say I want to only use genes
that are responsive to nobe to predict
the adult and OB phenotype so we're
excited by this because we kind of hit a
lot of dead ends and all there's similar
questions and we found it's really
interesting you know result out of
looking through Karl's data ii a
publicist i want to touch on is that
gene sparse regions tend to be tend to
have more pathogenesis related genes
whereas gene rich regions will tend to
have more you know basic life cycle
genes and the reasons for this are
numerous is coming out of their model is
coming out of sofyan commune's lab you
know if you have a gene sparse region
there's going to be more strain stuff
that you're going to have warm you
Haitians and is not the third one is not
necessarily implied by being jeans first
but you know one of the other metrics of
whether it's related to pathogenesis is
it expressed in planta and we found
which was really interesting is
basically one half of this model applied
to our system so this is a heat map
genes are bent and the x and y axis by
their distance to the nearest neighbor
and a three prime and five front
direction and the color is of all the
genes that are that far from the nearest
neighbor what is the mean ratio log
transform of their implant expression to
their control expression on a plate what
you see is that you know there's that
red patch in the corner of genes that
are far from both of their nearest
neighbors basically if a gene is over 10
KB from a neighboring gene on either
side the average ratio of in planta to a
zenok expression is about 200 versus a
baseline of about 1 so we see that
playing out essentially in a pepper
system you know gene sparse regions do
have genes that are highly expressed in
plaintive but we don't say the other
half of the hypothesis this is a similar
or of the models this is a similar heat
map you've got KB in both directions and
the color scale is the mean log
transformed D and yes that is the ratio
of nonsynonymous to synonymous
substitutions LOD nds means you have
very few nonsynonymous substitutions so
that is you know anything new is being
purged that stabilizing selection very
high D MDS is you've got you know
selection for diversity functional
diversity and essentially what we saw is
that you know genes and gene sparse
regions were not any faster to evolve so
we only get half of the model being
confirmed so backing up you know
somewhat backing up to our entire model
that we think about resistance under
we've been looking really at the
molecular scale you know in looking at
just a few genotypes but again you know
our group does a lot of field work we're
gonna move over to the extremely
extremely macro scale and thinking about
things on you know rather than thinking
about them on the tiny centimeter sample
scale think about them on the meters and
kilometers or at least acres scale so
the project that's been funding me for
the past two years has
basically centered around detecting
enemy lesions from aerial images from
UAVs unmanned aerial vehicles which is
how everybody prefers to say drones now
it sounds friendlier and so there's lots
of reasons you know I think many of us
now have heard various justifications
for why people phenotyping is useful you
know you want to have you want to remove
that bottleneck on all of your progress
you want to be have phenotyping that's
on the same scale and speed and accuracy
as you're genotyping but it's specific
about NLB you know in this specific
context why would you want to do this
there's kind of two groups of answers
the first is for being in genetics
actually think probably the most
relevant answer is that if you are
already flying a drone which i think is
gonna be more and more common for more
and more breeding programs you know if
you already have the images adding on
and you already have a pipeline that is
fairly simple to use adding on another
trait as much as difficult than you know
doubling the amount of traits you score
in the field you know obviously want
higher precision accuracy so Jesse
Pollan from our lab did some studies on
human accuracy for NLB short answer is
people are good but there's certainly
room for improvement and then I think
one was especially relevant for NOP is
that the main metric we take is after
flowering so that in a breeding program
what we measure is later in the season
you know far after flowering what we
measure is the percentage of diseased
leaf area it's very hard to score a
large area for pre flowering disease
traits because you're looking for pretty
rare lesions or you're looking for
something pretty rare so I think this
would you know if you can measure
something pre flowering you can also
choose the male parent and say you
theoretically double your gains but also
you know we don't work really in
management we don't really work on
fungicides or things of that age but we
want to be also be aware of how this
could be useful for management I think
similar thing more traits at once I
think you know all growers wanted in
fort they want to know whether it's
worth it to spray their fields with
fungicide given corn prices and the
probability of disease loss and one
that's pretty you know
like far out in the future but a few
groups are working on its variable rate
fungicide application I think this is
really exciting for larger areas you
know if you
wet spot in your field that's someone
that's gonna get hammered most likely
with disease worse and so if you can or
if you know it's coming from a direction
you know you can use the epidemiology of
it to save money so how did this project
work
you know we have field experiments of
various sizes you take drone images of
them thanks to tireless work from ethan
thick sr by Gore's lab go into some of
the troubleshooting of that we use human
annotations so basically showing where
the lesions are and we feed that into a
convolutional neural network CNN I'm
going to try to explain this briefly
including what a CNN is because I think
it's it's relevant for how all this
project works so a CNN is a class of
machine learning model it is the current
standard for recognizing objects from
images you know just in an automated
sense so when you upload a picture to
Facebook and it says oh this is Kyle's
face do you want to tag Kyle on this
what it is using is a CNN that has been
trained on images of Kyle's face so
that's what it's using and it's the same
with you know all of googles things any
self-driving car are using this basic
form of model it sounds more complicated
than the math behind it actually is the
central things these convolutional
layers of convolution is a mathematical
function that you can apply to matrices
these layers have filters which are
different matrices you slide the matrix
across an image which can also be
thought of as a matrix of n dimensions
and then essentially what it gives you
is this it gives you a high value
essentially where it sees a type of
feature and on the bottom layer it's a
pretty simple feature so it might be
vertical lines or the color blue or
something like that there's a pooling
layer which all that is is it's down
sampling the resolution like when you
shrink an image and there's a higher
convolutional layer that is looking at
combinations of the previous filters so
every time you move up a layer you're
looking at more and more complex
combinations of the layers below and
when you get to something on the third
level that's where you start saying okay
one of these 256 filters is going to
respond to lesions one of them might
racino or if you're optimizing it for
faces this is going to respond to Kyle's
face and then ultimately you can use
that to predict whether there's a lead
in the image or not or so the first
phase is you know the majority of it
which is annotated lesions train the
neural network and see how it does so we
have multiple field experiments you know
we're always running different disease
trials and we need to image those there
are a lot of challenges to imaging a
field an entire field at the level where
you can see NLB lesions I mean these
things are centimetres to millimetres
you know in size when you capture the
images we want these to be really
high-resolution much higher than people
are normally taking when they use drones
and economy which means that you need
low altitude you need low cut which
gives you little coverage you need to be
flying slowly because we don't want
motion blur once we analyze the images
you know we can't trust just anybody to
analyze NLP so the way that Google and
Facebook do it is they outsource all of
their annotations by looking at what who
you've tagged you know anytime that the
website asks you if you're human or not
and says click on all of the street
signs or transcribe this image or
something they are using you to
outsource what they want to train a
self-driving car to do they're usually
they've used you to outsource all that
work but obviously you know a random
person can't just say oh this is an OB
you know we also need a vast amount of
data to train a CNN so we kind of run
out this thing of human annotation it
was just a wall that we climbed over so
what I mean by human annotation is we
first tried just saying ok here's images
with an OB here's the ones without it
works super well so we have to count the
next level of detail which is okay
here's an picture a lot of lesions in
here this is actually off the drone it's
not cropped at all this is the actual
resolution that we were getting thanks
Nick thanks Ethan draw a line down the
axis do it for the next station do it
for the next station do it for all the
lesions of the image and then do that a
hundred thousand more times as a kid
imagine this was not fun it was mine but
ultimately that's the scale that we
needed to train these models accurately
it's ultimately what we do is then feed
them into the CNN we have some really
great computer science collaborators
formerly at Cornell now at Columbia and
what can we do so like in the simplest
view what can be
now we do that we could not before they
can take a handheld image beat it
through a network that has been trained
on tens of thousands of examples of what
a lesion looks like and where it is in
an image you can get out of heat map
where it says I think these regions are
NLB you know we can do this same with an
aerial image so again this is an on crop
this is straight off the drone we can
feed that into the network and then you
can see this is a little bit greater as
it were but you can do the same exact
thing you know here black is where they
seize the lesions and you know just
flipping from one to the other you can
see okay it's getting that it's getting
that it's getting there it's getting
this little one here so before I get to
the question that's the natural next
question which is how well are we doing
this or how good of a job are we doing I
want to bring in one last point which is
the idea of consensus so similar to when
you have a jar full of jelly beans and
if you have three people guessed the
mean of their guests is almost always
going to be better than any individual
guests you know the consensus of
multiple people the mean of their guests
is usually the most accurate same
concept here if you sub sample your
image data and your training data
slightly differently train three
slightly different CNN's you'll get
three slightly different predictions
which is that same image and here are
the three a B and C we were calling them
you know here are the heat maps from the
three here are the heat maps from the
three prediction networks and you can
see you know this one maybe is the one
on the left is maybe a little bit too
sensitive but that could be useful you
know when you're looking under different
light conditions so how good of a job do
these networks do you know on hand-held
images it's reaching ultimately about
97% accuracy and you can see the
validation set here you've got like
ninety percent accuracy where there each
one and then when you combine them you
get about 98 the difference between a
validation in a test set is that a
validation set is one that you can test
how good you're doing and then you know
maybe go back and say okay this method
didn't work let's go use this method
where as the test set you leave until
the very end and only look at once
because if you optimize your if you
optimize your model by looking at how it
does in the validation set and then you
test them in the validation set
obviously it's going to do a little bit
better
and the UAV images you know here's on
the XS you can see the epochs which is
like the different rounds of
optimization of the CNN and the y-axis
is the accuracy and it ultimately hit
tested accuracy of about 95% so 95% is
fairly good but you can imagine if you
were flying over a field and you looked
at a hundred thousand corn plants you
know you'd be getting five thousand
false positive it says and OB is here
where it's not which is unacceptable you
know first you're trying to screen a
large area so what we want to do what
I'm working on right now is basically
supplementing annotations using
crowdsourcing to improve our networks
performance so again this is what we
were doing so far we literally just went
through and drew lines at a hundred
thousand lesions and use that to train
the network and we've talked about using
polygons you know circling the lesions
but we just said there's no way we can
make that many you know it's just too
much of a time constraint but why do we
want polygons so here's an example this
is an image from a group actually also
at Cornell who's training a network to
recognize materials like carpet wood and
cement and things like that
here's what their network saw when it
was trained on point click so something
like click three points on the carpet
quick three points on something made of
wood here's what it saw when it was fed
polygons of that same thing so you can
see you know you're getting these crisp
annotations can defeating it a vast
amount more data when you circle all of
the points that are wood or carpet or
whatever than just clicking so we're
essentially you know on the same points
one and two we have our images we've
trained them on fairly low resolution
things but we're getting these kind of
blobs out it knows there is a lesion
there it has learned to recognize Asians
but we're not getting these crisp
outlines so we want to get polygon
annotations so the task is fairly
straightforward draw boundaries around
all lesions in this image do that a
hundred thousand times and the way that
we kind of went around this is divided
up into two things we've already done
this thing on the left
find the lesion which you know we tried
shopping that out to anonymous online
workers it did not work they are not
trained pathologist I've never seen
northern leaf blight not a surprise we
found is that when we basically do that
and then pass it over to people who
aren't experts you know we just randomly
hire for this task if actually works
pretty well
so I set up a platform and Amazon's
Mechanical Turk we were using it for a
couple different tests as well working
on annotation of like grassy weeds but
you can see is this is what they got
what we gave to them and they got pretty
minimal instruction - ewwww
oh and Mechanical Turk is an online
platform where you could hire people
anonymous on my workers for simple tasks
and they're typically paid by the task
and this is what the three people did so
you can see the outlines of red the area
of all three in green I mean they
honestly did a pretty good job I'm
guessing that none of them had like had
much experience with this specific corn
disease maybe they have they might've
venturing pathologists but I'm just
taking a stab that none of these people
they just you know humans can recognize
objects and file directions fairly well
other times they don't say hey so a lot
of this there was just a lot of data
sanitation that needs to happen with
this you know when are you obviously are
shopping stuff out and this is why we
haven't do it you know three people do
each task but ultimately it worked
fairly well so we were kind of thinking
and this mantra has come up a lot in the
project with his fast cheap and good
pick - in terms of cheap so we're paying
about twelve cents per lesion for cents
to each person then one of that big at
three and then one goes to Amazon its
blazingly fast so I think we're actually
paying a lot more than most I've looked
at a lot of other people's things we're
paying like several times more than most
of their tests so we get it done in a
few hours
if you post ten thousand things it'll be
done later that day and then the
ultimate question is how's the quality
how are these people doing so this is a
histogram of the overlap between all
pairs of polygons so the overlap is the
area of the intersect of them of the two
of them over the area of the union of
both of them so how much does it overlap
and it's between pairs of polygons in
one set of annotations that I put up on
em Turk and we can see is basically
three things first is that most of these
annotations are like around 75 percent
overlap which when you look at it like
on an image like that's pretty good for
these you know things that are taken
literally from a moving drone there is a
small subset of workers who are just
drawing random garbage but it turns out
actually thankfully they're pretty easy
to fill
they'll because these lesions are you
know they're only taking up like 10% 5%
of an image so it's really easy to see
when somebody's just you know putting in
garbage and we found out that was
actually pretty nice and then a lot of
the stuff in the middle is also useful
because what you found is that when we
when you look at an imaging like this is
kind of blurry but I think there's a
lesion here and then you hand that image
to three people who are generally
competent and seem to be doing a good
job and none of the three of them can
agree on where it is you probably gave
them a bad image so this is actually
serving as a nice I went back and looked
at hundreds of these images where people
who otherwise generally did well were
like could not agree on where the lesion
was and it was a really nice chest
basically say this image like we
shouldn't be feeding this into our
network it's you know low-quality
there's blur no.33 reasonable people
can't agree on what the lesion is and so
now kind of we're wrapping up the very
last piece which is how much does is
improve CNN performance once we've got
these things that basically move from a
crude line that is kind of drawn down
the X so the lesion as best I could get
to these polygons how much are we
improved so again dipping back to the
what can we do side you know it is
exciting our group was the first group
who and I think still is the only group
who has done recognition of diseases in
the field of just images taken you know
just without any sort of like correction
or clipping a belief and putting out on
background the sort of thing that you
could attach to a tractor or just walk
in the field take on your smartphone
with no background you know take from a
drone so it is really exciting there but
obviously you know looking at this heat
map we want to be able to get that more
refined into better so moving back to
the micro and macro kind of final
thoughts section you know it's as I'm
writing things it like and when you look
at all the projects together it can seem
kind of disparate cuz you're like okay
well here's an rna-seq experiment and
then here's machine learning with drone
images they they seem kind of disparate
even though they're about the same type
of system but I think the valuable thing
about that is that you know there's
plenty of stuff known and there's really
fascinating literature and components to
each of these scales of resistance and
you have to design different
to understand each of them but then also
you know the different scales kind of
which I say this cover for what the
other scales can't tell you so when
you're on the molecular scale you can
see okay here is something that's
invisible to the either it's happening
you know on a molecular scale of this
molecule interacting with that one you
know but it's not always taken into
account the fact that the pathogen is
moving through this three-dimensional
leaf which is trying to fight it off in
different ways at different points you
know a three-dimensional structure that
fights that when we're doing green
health and growth chamber experiments
you know we don't usually have the room
or the space or the ability at a time
you know deploy things which is looking
at diversity on the hundreds of plant
scales looking at natural diversity
where are the genes how do they perform
the field and then when we perform in
the field you know we're limited by how
much humans can get everyone who does
field work knows that at some point you
just physically can't get anymore hours
out of the week and out of your
undergrads and so that's you know we're
moving to this kind of final scale we're
saying we want this to be less and less
constrained by just how much we can walk
and see in a day and I think you know
all of these are extremely exciting
scales to be studied and so with that I
left I have a lot of things as you can
see because a lot of people have been it
could be excellent so Rebecca has been a
wonderful mentor both encouraging me to
do more out there things like machine
learning from film images but also to
focus and write my papers so both
keeping me on track and encouraging me
to try new things
Gillian turgid and Mike Gore it's
incredibly valuable to have two people
who have questions on like hardcore
fungal genetics and meiosis or on you
know how we shouldn't be processing this
data flow for high people phenotyping
that have excellent people to ask the
Nelson lab personnel and staff
specifically our longtime lab manager
Judy Copeman who's my compatriot in the
field for basically all my field seasons
greenhouse and field personnel anyone
who works in the greenhouse and field
knows it they're the ones can make
everything run the Nelson Lab has a
wonderful cohort of grad students former
and current who are always getting
really excellent advice about everything
even a nick from the Mike Gore's lab are
the ones who for - acuity and amount of
effort to get our drone images taken the
Lipson lab at Columbia's our
science collaborators have been really
truthful to work with synapses is a
wonderful organization and I say that
not just pandering because most people
in here a grad students but it's a it's
a great organization to just you know
have lots of opportunities and outlets
to talk about plant biology obviously
the love and support and scholarly mind
of Lauren Bukowski who is flying back
from Japan right now I think and then
funding from the NSF national products
initiative in the past two years the NSF
Dr Mays grant right here for my first
three years and the joint genome
Institute who fun to be a lot of the RNA
seek work and fungal genome sequencing
with that yeah probably a lot especially
about the germination success of the
Canadia I mean so you know so when he
spray Canadia these asexual spores in
the leaf for spraying thousands to tens
of thousands of hundreds of thousands of
them and we really think from looking at
the leaves I mean you know it's like not
many of them succeed into becoming a
lesion so I think that's probably what
we're missing is the germination success
of the Canadia I mean I think there's
lots to miss there and so that's the RTC
paper that has come out about Esther
Asuka that we were worried if they'd
scooped us you know that was really in
just the first three days that was I
think their own time point was like one
day post inoculation
oh yeah sunny day running dirty
background and how would that influence
their CNN I picked the nicest images
oh yes so the question if I did here is
about you know these have a dark
background and then as well so this is
obviously a Kanaan a cloudy day you've
got really nice contrast it's taken
earlier in the season where everything's
dark green still you know that was not
the question but I think we're all the
point and you've got this dark
background all the leaves already pop
out you know if it's bright and sunny
you know how does this perform so the we
have a lot of images that look a lot
worse than this where the lesions are
less clear you have images from later in
the season where you start getting the
confusing things of you know senescence
of the lower leaves versus what an
ovulation is you know we have plenty of
images where and especially you know you
can imagine with the leaf you get this
big sunny reflective patch right where
the leaf curls over because I've taken
these images straight down yeah and so
the the accuracy performance values that
you saw the 95 and 98 well 95 to 97%
yeah so those are all using that's using
both shady images and sunny images it's
using images from earlier in the season
where things are still this dark blue
green see some things later in the
season where things are starting to sub
s so we took a fair amount of pictures
over you know time courses and different
conditions good questions questions when
you're sampling your gene expression
d-10 tissue are you interaction a lot of
it's presumably going to be yes so the
sampling was done basically around the
lesion for 10 days post inoculation with
these what you generally see well I'll
take a while for me to scroll back but
we generally see at 10 days in the
growth chamber with these backgrounds is
you know the lesions are starting to
form but it's not totally so as PDF so
it's not totally crusty like this it
looks more similar to this HT 2 here so
this would be yeah so we've done
different things so the sampling for
this experiment was done by Santiago
Medeiros mostly from our lab before he
moved under postdoc and then I've been
sending another grown the one with QT
ELISA Lyons
we tossed around a lot of different
ideas to basically minimize sample
variance and for that experiment what I
ultimately settled on was basically
taking a big swath the same size as what
we were sampling for histopathology so
you're averaging out a fair amount of
area around around where the lesions
incipient but also so we inoculate with
the walls and so you get most of our
spores in a pretty obvious band so
basically most that most of the
infection in the growth chamber when we
were all not good is happening within
about two inches my impression is and a
lot of these humming by a trophic
interactions like 48-hour yeah so that's
another is this such a different kind of
interaction I mean yes I think it I mean
so the majority is on weak pathogens and
magnet for thin rice like what we had to
compare this to
and then as well so we've also been you
know a collaborator people on cardi
works in southern leaf bite which is
called a Hemi betrothed but that by
atrophic phase lasts like 12 hours so
then as a question of is it quiescent in
general this is fairly similar to what's
been observed in Magna Bertha where she
was pretty rich I don't have a good
answer for in terms of how the Hayes
relative to the wheat penny by drops
this is one thing that we oh yeah so the
question was have we've been able to
test the accuracy with regards to
different these plates so there was one
thing we really wanted to do with the
outside of the grant and basically we're
not able to do because there's so many
complications to the earlier steps but
yeah so I mean northern leaf plate and
say and frack you'll see fight they look
really similar I mean like when you've
seen them a lot you can like okay I can
tell some diagnostic things but they
look really really similar so I think
yeah that's a that's the obvious you
know a next question to ask
[Applause]
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at Cornell edu